I was quite taken by these numbers, actually.
When you think about the what, thousands and thousands,...
…seven thousand edible plants worldwide,...
…and we only eat just over 400 of them.
Why is that?
Why aren't we growing and exploring more options?
I think it just happened by chance alone.
Actually, our ancestors about 10,000 years ago, selected a handful of plants,...
...to domesticate because they were appealing.
They provided a very good source of food.
They, over time, provided good yields.
And they were very good at feeding the world.
And that's why they were spread around.
And these plants are maize, rice and wheat.
And there's still great crops to grow and eat.
The problem is that if one of them fails,...
…if one of them is not resilient to climate change,...
…then, we're going to be in trouble because we rely on them so heavily.
And so, what we propose is to diversify our food systems,...
...to rely on the very broad diversity of edible plants that's out there.
But, how easy will it be to actually scale up,...
…the production of some of these foods?
I think it's very dependent.
So, there are about 7,000 edible plants out there,...
…and 400 of those are already crops, either minor or major crops.
And so, it's very plant specific,...
…whether they're going to be scaled up or not.
…and something that we have to keep in mind at the forefront,...
...is to make sure that the populations that already rely on these plants,...
…are still able to access these plants.